trois en bas en bas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Applaudissements]
différents
[Musique]
Je dirais que si nous vendions une centaine
d'armes de poing,
20 d'entre elles il
y a cinq ans
étaient destinées à la multiplication des femmes
étrangères
[Musique]
J'aime le look de  les semi-autos
et je n'ai pas vraiment été avec eux
juste avec mon mon père
et je suis seul à la maison
380s neuf millimètres 40s 45s tu te
souviens du genre d'arme que ton père aurait pu
avoir avec n'importe quel type de calibre
euh  Je ne veux rien de gros,
rien que je ne pourrai pas gérer,
dans la mesure où si quelqu'un
venait dans la maison,
je ne pourrais pas le filmer, laissez-moi
vous montrer quelque chose sur Smith et
Wesson.
il a beaucoup de caractéristiques de sécurité
par rapport à certaines armes qui n'en ont pas,
vous ne voudriez pas l'utiliser pour le
tir sur cible parce que c'est un
canon très court, quelque chose comme ça
avec un canon plus long,
nous avons essayé différents  euh
un soir par semaine
comme le vendredi soir et
[Musique]
euh
féminin
[Musique]
Les armes à feu sont faites pour plaire aux femmes, il
peut y avoir plus esthétique
et euh
les armes à feu et les annonceurs
[Musique]
derrière
l'autre solution de Dieu
étrangère
pour aller suivre une formation  et apprends
à utiliser correctement une arme à feu
[Musique]
étrangère
Je leur ai dit qu'ils étaient complètement cinglés
étrangers
[Musique]
allez
étrangère
[Musique] va te faire
[ __ ] d'ici, bien, fous le camp d'
ici, bien, je veux dire,
ça va  pour empêcher quelqu'un
de se [ __ ] d'ici, bon,
fous le camp d'ici, bon, fous le camp
d'ici
[Musique] [
Musique]
qui est un magasin d'armes
conçu
à l'étranger
et un endroit pour mettre une petite arme
donc oui
et
tu peux tirer  ça s'est fait facilement, disons que vous
transportiez des millions de personnes,
beaucoup de ces gens sont sortis
avant que les lois n'entrent en vigueur et,
fondamentalement,
ils pourraient vendre beaucoup plus d'armes à feu qu'ils n'en
avaient au cours
de l'année précédente,
merci
[  Musique]
statistiques
sans crainte que quelqu'un essaie de
me l'enlever
[Musique] les
gentils n'ont pas les armes que
nous sommes prêts à tuer
[Musique]
merci